now is the last night music city  meltdown Juliette Barnes went after  concert goers after a few unhappy fans  began taunting and heckling the country  superstar and what followed with a  five-minute rant about being loved after  which point Juliette abruptly ended the  concert what is there anything you want  to say to me I think we should cancel  the New Year's Eve party anything else  what else is there then what is going on  why won't you talk to me what would you  like to hear me say that the past two  months of my life have been a living  hell that every morning it's a struggle  just to get out of bed why would I  burden you with that  just want to lift on  [Music]  I'm here for you okay maybe we should  just get away for a while